Was this your question? Is the food sensitivity shown coffee?
And that's about caffeine. Well again, I don't know. You'd have to actually contact the company that
did the food sensitivity test. So I don't know that the food sensitivity test that they said coffee
is caffeine. It may be something else in the coffee that they're tested. And that would be a good
question for them. That is chocolate also a problem. Typically chocolate and coffee are going to be
measured. I know the Cyrix tests for coffee and chocolate, milk chocolate, dark chocolate.
And they separate that out. So I don't know that it's the caffeine and the coffee that they're
tested. That would be a good question. Because if it isn't the caffeine and it's approaching
in the coffee that they're tested, then you could actually use like a black tea in your coffee
animal. So you'd get the caffeine as a stimulant to the vagal nerve. So good question. Good line of
thought there. So you might want to reach out to the company and see what it is that they were testing.